phd
all right we are currently live right
now so we're with everyone here on
youtube and we have a special guest
today
we have kevin samuels in the building uh
for a lot of our audience some of you
may not know who kevin samuels is so uh
kevin i figured i'd just give you a
chance
do you prefer me just go by the first
name is that fine yeah that's fine
all right all right so um yeah if you
could just give a brief introduction
uh because some of our audience is all
over europe and things like that so they
may not be aware
so for hello welcome how we doing
um my name is kevin samuels i'm a
professional
corporate and personal image consultant
uh my job is to make you look good smell
great and be the best version of
yourself each and every day
i make video content on youtube i
started making video on content on
youtube
in areas of men's fashion well in
fashion
and equal parts of pregnancy viewing
but as time progressed i decided to
start making
uh videos and content about the other
parts of image
which people only think of images the
appearance it's actually four parts
appearance behavior communication
digital footprint
i start making videos about the behavior
communication and digital footprint of a
person
which inevitably led to personal and
professional
outcomes and challenges and that's kind
of why i've become
gain most of my attraction you know
i may be an image consultant by day but
on at night i'm kind of known as a guy
who hosts a
live stream monday through friday uh
10 p.m eastern standard time or really
get into
relationships uh and the issues between
today's men and women and what so many
of my clients
male and female come back and report
that they've been experiencing in their
actual
day-to-day life to try to get the kind
of outcomes they want on paper so
it's a long a long way around saying
that i come
it's come full circle uh like i said you
can look good smell good be the part
but if you don't walk it talk it that's
not who you are maybe that's not how you
look online
people aren't going to get the kind of
outcomes they want and for me
it's all about results and outcomes
that's what an image consultant really
concerns himself with
and coming from a corporate environment
sales environment i'm concerned about an
outcome
the process is cool but the outcome so
that's uh i did the nutshell all right
um so yeah just to start this off at the
end of the day um
for us this is like meant as an
opportunity to talk to folks who we may
agree or disagree with on certain things
and then do so in a civil manner so
for us this opportunity is kind of
exciting because as you might know um
a lot of your videos are making the
rounds people constantly send them to us
as conversation stars and i think they
are good for that reason alone
because irrespective of how people may
feel about the things that you're saying
it's clear that
your sentiments your views do echo what
a lot of uh
people feel and a lot of people view the
world and it's important for us to be
able to discuss these things
uh on open platforms uh so i figured we
would start this you know i
i thought it would be the best way we
could do this is just to discuss some of
the stuff that i think people really try
to hold against you
uh do you like recognize that like a lot
of people see you as a controversial
figure
um i recognize that there are people on
the loud people online say that but when
i'm out
in my life i'm in here in atlanta and i
spent the entire day out yesterday
and i took no fewer than 30 pictures
with young men
under 30 black men saying thank you you
speak for me
so um i i separate online
uh very much you guys did a video asking
about a content creators
responsible for their comment section
and now right
i can't echo the sentiments no i'm not
it's an open platform
you know if a video has a hundred
thousand views and it has
eight thousand eight thousand comments
uh
if you look you see there's a pattern
there tend to be a very vocal minority
of people who go around saying the same
things and starting the same
issues but rarely do any people anyone
talk about
the substance the actual information it
always be goes into the personal the ad
hominem which i don't
i don't deal with that's fair that's
fair there is quite a lot of ad hominems
and a lot of things are like in terms of
uh
people characterizing your views um
which is not necessarily something that
i want to get too into i do want to
discuss some of the ideas though
which i thought would be a great
starting point but
like i said when we said we were going
to bring you on a lot of people had a
lot of things to say
me personally if i'm being very honest i
did quite a bit of research decided to
watch
quite a few live streams amen you got
like a lot of two hour videos
uh so sometimes it can be very daunting
to get through
a lot of content especially live streams
but there's a lot of quality stuff that
i enjoyed in there
and i think for the most part um a lot
of my personal views
and a lot of my ideas did overlap in
regards to dating gender norms things
like that
and in doing a lot more research i also
realize that most people don't watch you
in full they catch clips on world star
hip hop or instagram
and feel like they get a holistic view
of what you do
do you feel like um as a result of the
way social media functions you're often
misrepresented
well that's part of that's part of the
gig
i mean how many people often
misrepresent robert downey jr or anybody
else they
see on as iron man or anything else
that's part of this thing
right and i remember i remember that
one of the common conceptions like your
videos are so long well
there's also a generational thing too
you cannot present
complex ideas in short form i mean
look at twitter twitter is the wawa west
because you're limited by
characters 120 characters and more often
than not people destroy themselves
on twitter because it's almost
impossible to take human beings how
we've evolved over time
and condense it in 120 characters
there's no context
right so oftentimes when people are
introduced to me they're introduced to
me from
places that are salacious i mean if you
are familiar with the national acquirer
star magazine the things that are sold
in the checkout isle of the grocery
store
it's not it's not high journalism it's
ufo sightings next to brad angelina
i mean that's what it is and they're
trying to get you to buy the magazine to
see the gossip but here's the thing
we become a society where
that that kind of information the
national
inquirer is on the same level as
the new york times the wall street
journal the economists the financial
times
and the washington post uh they're all
trying to make a profit building a
business and they're going to put
whatever
out that sells what they need to get
sold it's what
to us as the consumers to decide where
we rank the information
okay and so when it comes to the
criticism that you do receive in terms
of
its validity or not are there any things
in regards to the way that you've done
things thus far
that you uh felt like you could have
better adjusted
or you feel some type of way don't
mistake this i'm not saying like yo you
got to apologize for something
i'm just curious is throughout all the
criticism and a lot of like the
nonsensical noise has ever been times
where you stop deposit be like you know
what i could have done better there
well i mean it'll be rather arrogant to
say we can't do better but
it's in the moment how many times does a
pro player go back and say man i wish
i'd had a chance to take that
a different way i would have did this
versus that my marshall
if you if you've ever been in a ring in
martial arts
sometimes you win sometimes you lose
when you lose you say man i wish i saw
that coming i knew he was going to do
this
i should have slipped this and did that
but in the moment you did what you did
how many blooper reels do we have of nfl
or nba or
mlb players losing world championships
or world series
by making an error let's see we allow
errors
in sports we don't allow errors online
especially
for content creators that we disagree
with it
never really comes down to the
information
it comes down to how you feel about the
case in point uh in some of my most
viral moments
i have on good authority that the the
some of the very people i've spoken to
in their quiet reflection have come back
and said you know what i needed to hear
that
you know that's actually the tough part
about watching it because sometimes you
know
some folks will say like how could you
believe you said that now watch the
video and i'm like
no she's uh definitely being
unreasonable and i think at one point
she's going to watch us back and
recognize
um or not no maybe not but i'll be like
and objectively speaking as a third
party
but if and if they don't is that a
reflection upon me i mean
you we went to school our instructors
did the best they could to teach us but
we were at our levels we couldn't hear
did it make the information any less
valid but how many people say i didn't
like miss
mccann because she was a a real witch in
biology
wow i love miss mccann she challenged me
to become better
that's what it comes down to when i talk
to people people need to realize a few
things one
these are all voluntary consensual
conversations with adults who seek me
out
so whether you like it or not i'm not
trolling anybody
i'm sitting in my area doing what i do
and someone says i want your advice
knowing knowing what you do as well and
don't know what you do and and if you
listen to my show what
i have thousands and thousands and
thousands of hours of shows
three years i talked to me and before i
even started talking to women
and what people what people focus on is
the last bit
they don't look at the previous like
like the
average at best video that was 23
minutes
yup but both people focus on the final
seven
and when and the funny thing is i've
heard people say i did research on these
guys
and so you spend more time doing this
so-called
research on me than you do actually
asking
hmm let me watch the beginning video
from beginning to end
because that's what i've saw more often
anything when i put the full video up
there were actually content creators
making retraction videos
now but but let's be honest it's the
controversy it's the
it's the what gets your goat that uh
animated people to do something
and i will say this about that moment it
would be extremely arrogant of me to
think it's about me
after that video reached a couple
hundred thousand people on worldstar
what that video did i said when i was in
miami this is
this is not about kevin samuels it's way
past me oh of course of course yeah no
this is clearly
uh in regards to the divide between men
and women some of the ideas that we have
about each other and it just kind of
reflected within
that conversation but i actually want to
stop right on the topic that you said in
regards to like
people viewing it like you don't talk to
to men
and so i decided to do some dig and i
actually found some clips so if you
don't mind i'm actually going to play
some clips so you're talking to men and
offering
very similar advice is that fine they're
public they're public
oh yeah yeah don't worry don't worry
about it i mean i'll leave it up
okay all right so let me just pull that
right up here
so i'm going to just play this clip real
quick you are you living an interesting
life i mean your third grade
working in the warehouse what are you
doing that's interesting i mean
i like to work out okay yeah really i
mean i like this
don't dabble in it just one second i'm
just gonna play the clip i'll let you
guys know when it's done so everyone's
watching
you are you living an interesting life i
mean you're 34 working in the warehouse
what are you doing it's interesting
i mean i like to work out okay
i mean i like this so i like to go out
you know places and visit places and
stuff
you know i don't know you doing this
interesting see i didn't have i didn't
have none of that when i was a kid man
i didn't go to my uh proms or nothing
like that and what
and at 34 years old that's your
responsibility to address
because nobody's concerned but your own
no one cares what you did not have
that's your problem that's it i didn't
have a father that's my problem
everybody got something how tall are you
i'm only five
five just
you got two struggles already you can't
be short and fat
yeah two strikes you got to pick a
struggle
how much about how much do you make a
year
um 40 000. how old are you
for almost 40 so you're underemployed
too
yeah all right bro so you so short
don't have to worry about that but your
weight and your money
[ __ ] with your confidence oh
why would the female of the species want
to take your
genes and put them into the next
generation
correct short mean you're fat
underemployed and
unambitious should should males like
that
in the in the animal world be able to
mate
no at 38 years old
is this what you thought you'd be in
life no
and what are you doing about it um
working out no i'm looking at your fat
that's true see this is why i have these
conversations because a lot of this
stuff gets
lost in the sauce when you start talking
about women in these red pills and all
this other kind of stuff
this ain't got nothing to do with women
see in five foot five
five five you should be you should be in
shape
for you yo you have zero confidence
um and you're a quitter um
you're underperforming and you lack
ambition
you need to go enroll in martial arts a
boxing somewhere
and let somebody knock the [ __ ] out of
you
because you don't know who you are a man
really
gets know who he is when he has to taste
his own blood
uh i kind of disagree with some of the
things you're saying uh okay
how old are you 20. okay why does your
opinion matter
uh everyone's opinion is valid no that
doesn't twenty-year-old
guy who's done no [ __ ] you got you got
an opinion
but you have no limited experience
you're 20. oh i'm 50.
oh sorry i just i don't know
i just feel like you're going really
hard on my life i don't like it what
would your father say
no it's not that it's just we're living
in a society full of women
who just truthfully just don't deserve
half of the stuff that you're
saying like they don't deserve really
okay tell me what happened the last time
you had a relationship with a woman
it was terrible okay when okay how long
ago was it well
four years ago okay you do say that
so you were in there from 15 to 16. how
was she
uh can't recall but about the same age
hold on hold on that does not compute
would it be fair to judge all of
womankind
by the thing that one with one
fifteen-year-old girl did
five years ago no
right so when you tell them when you
start telling me how women aren't this
women aren't that i'm telling you you
have not had enough experience with
women to know
anything first world problems you have
first world problems all right so i just
finished it it was a six minute clip of
you talking to young men
and the reason why i played it was not
to dunk on these young men or anything
like that
uh but it's to show that you keep the
exact same energy for people who say
outlandish things on both sides
provided you have the opportunity and i
kind of just wanted to play those clips
to show that sure it was funny i had a
good laugh even though i edited it and
i've heard these before
they never stopped being funny um but
the
the advice is poignant and and when when
people say oh he hates
black women i'm like well i've heard him
say the exact same things or the exact
same type of advice
to young men who were in need um so i
guess i wanted to just play those clips
to kind of showcase that
okay um now if i were both of you
gentlemen are you comedians yes
um yeah so it's funny that one clip
about you know you're this tall you
weigh this much
that got a lot of traction but that
video sat on my vid
on my channel from january of last year
and oh and it became when people start
kind of
going through my catalog of videos uh
what they never said is you're toxic to
black men
i just asked myself of some of the
criticism that things that
are leveled at men if we just
switch the genders that would be okay
and the and the guy in that video
actually booked the session with me
and when they went looking for him he
came on show said no thank you that guy
helped me out
see men understand
more readily than i find that men more
readily understand than most women
when we are in some delusional spaces or
we're not getting the outcome because
the world gives men
more often a real world accounting of
where you are
we get rejected we get a real world
litmus test a real world temperature
check
so while many men will take the advice
and i will tell you
the people who book sessions with me
primarily want to hear the truth
from out from what i see and and about
an
outcome and they're more often than not
they're thankful of it because
their outcomes improve so
like i said yesterday walking around
every time i met every time i'm out in
public it's
nothing but love from men and black
women matter of fact most black women
come up to me and say something like
this
i i love what you do i watch a show all
the time
can i have an autograph can i get the
picture i watch your videos sometimes
with my friends and while
some of them may not like what you say
they have to agree with one or two
really dislike it but you know what i
normally tend to find
there's usually a man with this woman
and when i do have i've had some women
who did not like it especially when i
first went viral
i would go out places and women i had
this episode of bloomingdale's where i
had like 30 people around me
having like a real world i've been
looking for you for a while
but walking away with a better
understanding because
they just watched a clip they never
asked the question
i run shows on my platform that i call
free smoke
where i allow critics and detractors to
come talk to me in real time
about the issue who else
i mean so it's about an exchange of
ideas and more often than not
critics end up walking away saying i
didn't know that
all this research and stuff people
supposedly do but this
it amazes me all this research they seem
to do but they never
seem to understand or research the the
topics
the things i'm talking about it's it
almost always comes down to the
who are you to say this you're too harsh
or what's the solution and then that's
what i also reject too
why don't i have to be the oracle at
delphi to fix everything
everyone people al roker can talk about
the weather he's not expected
to fix global warming yeah i mean that's
just nonsensical stuff the idea that you
have to have a solution to every problem
that you
why are you complaining if you have no
solution or why are you bringing this
it's it's
it's you know it's terrible ideas um and
and i agree with you vehemently on that
point
preacher wants to jump in with something
yeah well you know you do say that you
focused on the outcome
and um not everybody responds to the
same
this is the same way uh uh not not
everybody
responds to the same way they're all the
same way the same things right
so what i'm saying is just about the
delivery people have been complaining
about the delivery you know
if you uh order a pizza and the delivery
man you know order
he gives you your pizza and it's upside
down at the end of the day it's still a
pizza but the delivery is [ __ ]
up right so maybe if you're focused
because you said that
earlier that you focus on the outcome
and you know that some people will not
respond well
to how you deliver
those those truths uh you can call it
whatever you want but
that truth that you have to deliver to
them uh
is is there a possibility you could
change the way you deliver
stuff just for people to understand
better because if if it's the message
if the point of all this is the message
then you want the message to come across
so maybe try another
would you consider trying another way um
i will tell you why i won't i'll tell
you why i won't because i've had
i've had no fewer than a dozen women
come
on and tell me it's the way you deliver
and then i ask them who does
something on my instagram right now who
does
give you critical advice advice that you
don't want to hear the way you want to
and there's always a cricket pause i'm
like who did who gives it to you the
right way
and the most consistent person i've had
someone say is
dr umar johnson and i'm like that's
because he
because he calls you queens and this and
that
i'm not going to do that because i don't
believe what he believes
but here's the thing the late great
patrice o'neill and bill burr
they've got a lot of work and they knew
their delivery
it is impractical to ask everyone to ask
me to
try to make a situation to fit everyone
there are people who are just not going
to like my pizza
period i could deliver it to him on a
golden chariot on a platinum plate
encrusted with diamonds
they will still say it's not hot enough
because
two plus two is four and the problem is
only with the delivery
when the truth when the reality is
inpalatable it's not digestible then we
want to make it about everything else
and see that's what i reject more than
anything else especially being a man of
color
a black man everyone
rush limbaugh could deliver what he
delivers simon cowell could do what he
does and become an american idol
gordon ramsay can be hell's kitchen
because you're a stupid little effing
monkey
but if i just happen to say something
that you don't like in a particular way
i'm supposed to repackage repurpose
i am sick and tired of men having to
apologize for being men
all the time when i have heard some of
the most egregious things
on public tv online today what are some
of these very woke women
yeah i mean on this note you you know we
agree with you when we're framing these
questions it's not meant to be
our thoughts i know i get it and this
but i like this part of because people
need to understand just like what jordan
peterson did up in canada
the pendulum needs to swing back to the
point of ladies no matter how you like
it
when when the dust is cleared and
settled are you getting the outcomes you
are wanting in life
if not then let's talk about a different
delivery
but as long as you understand that it's
not necessarily our views we just want
to try
to debunk and understand yeah yeah i get
it it's the general
you know what i mean obviously i come
from a military background so
you already know what time it is all
right so so when we talk about delivery
it's like
yeah okay maybe the way we talk in the
army is not for you but guess what [ __ ]
nobody asked you to sign up
right and so there has to be some level
of accountability on the people who
choose to come on like i can't believe
it's delivery well
maybe it's just not for you in the same
token you know when i watch
the real that delivery's not for me it
vehemently makes me want to puke do i
get on
some platforms and say yo you shouldn't
be able to talk that way there's
different strokes
for different folks and i think i
recognize that your way of talking
really appeals to
especially a lot of men uh because one
it's very direct it's blunt it's not
sugar coated i can't personally stand it
when people try to package things to me
in a kind and nice way it feels like
they're pampering me and i don't need
that and i think it's
part of why i think people like jordan
peterson became very popular they just
came on and said man clean your room
take responsibility
and i think you do that in your own way
and so i'm fine with the delivery
personally
i just recognize a lot of people are not
going to like it and that's what it
really
rubs i think a lot of people the wrong
way but then when a young
young black woman comes up and says
kevin samuels is the reason
i'm engaged and she comes in and says i
called into his show
last fall last summer and he gave me
some direct advice that i did not want
to hear
but it's that advice that started the
chain reaction of events to where
now i got engaged in aruba on january
1st
young black woman i have a facebook
group where i have a
men and women in a group that i kind of
hand select i call it the mix
and all i do is put like-minded people
in the room in nature taking the scores
over six months eight couples have
gotten together eight black couples and
three engagements
one two three and i i won't actually
just push back on that so so
i i hear the idea that you've had some
success um
how do you measure whether or not your
methodology is really working
when most of the time the ideas that
you're getting back are the successes
and i ask this because maybe you offer
advice to a lot of people and it doesn't
go anywhere does that factor into
whether or not your method is affected
one
and the second thing i would add um
i wouldn't think this is your fault per
se but if we're just looking at the net
positive for example right
there have been folks who've come on
your show their choice their own mistake
and as a result of it being broadcasted
everywhere
maybe their self-esteem dropped et
cetera et cetera does that factor into
the equation of whether or not
your methodology is effective and then i
raise that question no because two
things can be true at the same time
okay i mean the fact of the matter is i
don't proport myself to be a marriage
consultant
a matchmaker there are people out here
selling books courses seminars
and where there were their results where
are people coming saying i followed x y
i followed him or i followed her and it
was results this and
they made those videos because they're
saying this worked for me
and the stuff that you liked and it
sugar coated or whatever
where's your result i don't get paid for
the result
matter of fact i have not monetized any
of this i haven't sold a book a t-shirt
a course a seminar or whatever so
i cannot be responsible for what an
adult does with their self-esteem
that's yourself the main thing i push
more than anything else is
therapy what do you mean you push
therapy is it like you tell people
i say we need therapy and especially in
that community we need therapy we left
we left childhood slavery went directly
into trying to become a full citizen we
have
issues that are in the west
that are unique but then we also have
cultural issues
but i'm assuming i'm dealing with fully
functional autonomous human beings that
can make a choice
that's quite the stretch that's quite
the assumption well that's the
assumption i'm because i don't
look also if you talk to an alcoholic an
addict you don't get them you don't
you have an intervention they don't sit
there and hey
you know maybe you shouldn't slam so
much junk
i mean it's ridiculous because where
let's just flip this paradigm let's just
flip this
what you just said valid let's see where
they're asking women to do this
where they're asking women to moderate
the tone what what do you
what you tell call men are trash and
they're toxic and it is what about when
a man feels so bad that his
masculinity is being questioned and
every time he decides to try to stand up
and face the world
that you're telling him he's a bad
person what about with these men who are
committing suicide at a higher rate and
anything else homeless
higher rates of depression imprisonment
all these things we don't care about
what happens with men
it's only when we start talking straight
talk that
through women then all of a sudden it
becomes
oh but then you have a woman who has a
nerve to
offer a curfew to men in the uk
yeah he would have been cancelled right
then
thanos could have snapped fast enough
for him to be gone
um this is something i actually wanted
to do earlier on but i think we kind of
moved past it just the way we started
but um you sometimes use terminal
terminology that i think a lot of people
don't understand
um things like the idea of a high value
man and
hypergamy now i understand high
programming specifically i feel like
high value man um if you could could you
define that for people because i i think
everyone wants to know how you use it
and
and and what it really means well first
of all high value man is not my term
high value has been with us for for a
long time
um i'm 52 years old and
the notion of i need a man to be making
six figures or more came around 1985
83 to 85 right before newsweek
made that uh cover called the marriage
crunch so basically this six-figure
thing
it means making a hundred thousand
making the hundred thousand dollars or
more annually
and adjust it for dallas houston dallas
dollars so roughly around ten thousand
dollars a month because
ask most women and they want a man
earning
at least double what they made or so
this this mythological figure i didn't
make the six figure number
okay uh but high value and hypergamy
linked together in two ways i've just
put a framework around
a higher value uh and that money needs
to be made for at least five years in a
row you can't just have a
great year you need to have some
consistency well when you say high value
is that only along
monet monetary lines or is it on any
other access
if i can let me get to yes no okay well
you're asking
okay you're asking two questions i value
first is you have to make a certain
amount of money for a certain amount of
time
men who are already high value recognize
you as a peer
or possible peer you're either already
there or you have the potential
the most important thing about being
high value is you have a network of high
value men and other people
what you do needs to be linkedin level
meaning visibility
meaning people can't just sit back and
uh
have to assume what you do uh linkedin
level
meaning i'm the vp of mergers and
acquisitions at
a bank of america not just i'm an
entrepreneur what does that mean
uh linkedin level and then and most
important
i think useful to others in the group
they're no high value loaners
if you're not useful to anybody else
what value do you have
to most people and what i did is i look
back across time and i said what what
what were the men who separated
themselves from all other men what are
some of the things they had in common
irrespective of relationship what did
men value in other men on any continent
any time frame
uh any economy any kind of governmental
setup
so the next question you asked about
hypergamy hypergamy is just the notion
that females will consolidate on the
highest value male 1
yeah no i actually understand that you
know i actually understand the hypergamy
comment but i actually wanted to come
back to um the high value man so you
talked about the status in regards to
having a position that's like definable
and as well as the income are there any
other axes that you would
also equate to high value uh you can but
i
not in general because here's a problem
okay go ahead you have to overlay this
globally
your morals and ethics my morals and
ethics you can be a high-value atheist
you can be a high-value nihilist but
when
we try to put in these moral things
those are modifiers that you're welcome
to put on there
but you cannot say that because a person
doesn't show your particular moral
or or religious or philosophical
concerns
that they're value by to other men
is diminished see people focus on the
money part but the money part is the
most fine
is the most definable and the least
important
because six figures is 100 dollars 120
a year roughly 10 000 a month or so that
can go up to billions but there are
plenty of people who make millions of
billions who are not high value
they make a lot of money i do not i do
not i do not classify
automatically people in entertainment
athletics
uh and music is high value
i think you need to be at least 30 years
old because you to make be high value
because it's almost impossible
to make the kind of income you i'm
talking about
from your own competency for a
consistent period of time and be under
30.
i don't know many people who come
directly out of high school
and about 25 that are making 100 dollars
a year
it takes some time um i need to i gotta
do something real quick can i pick a
pause real quick can we come right back
yeah you can take a pause and then we'll
just uh carry on with the stream first
moment here
yeah okay um yes
sorry go ahead preach the thing about
that is that and what i own
i feel like people fail to understand
and that's what i wanted to
before it takes the pause that i want to
say
is that i feel like it's not
necessarily people think that it's
something that he put out there
right but from what i understand it's
really is reflection of what the world
is so he's not dictating he's not
dictating how the world should be
but it's really just a reflection when
you talk about high value that's not
him putting it out there and how it
should be therefore not his vision
or our division of anybody is just
how things are and how people in if
you're talking about the dating world
it's how most of the things function
right so people really easily and
quickly say like
oh he's like that because he thinks like
that but it's really maybe just
a representation of what the world is
more than
what you think it is what you cast out
there because
no one no one person can be like you
know what the way i'm thinking is like
that i think that
it's really just a representation of
what the world is of how you see them
yeah yeah or what
i think that's how he's defined the
concept it's just a matter of like is it
as
valid as it today as it has always been
i think there's like a lot of questions
in regards to
all right well this is what a high value
man is but in a modern society where
yes women are still hypergamous despite
making you know just as much money and
just just to be clear
i want to make sure everybody
understands what hypergamy means because
these words are thrown around you don't
want to google them
hypergamy is a term used in social
sciences for the act
or practice of a person marrying a
spouse of a higher caste or social
status than themselves
the antonym is hypogamy which refers the
inverse marrying a person of a lower
social class or status now
these kind of terms have been around
forever uh you know people have been
marrying up and down
uh for survival for family joining and
stuff like that
and in modern society uh hypergamy
generally refers to like marrying
someone who has higher wealth than you
more education uh you know bigger larger
whatever
and yeah and then man do the opposite
uh just a moment here let me just switch
back since he's back uh
okay i'm gonna have to fix this real
quick
uh yes so um you you were talking about
the fact that let me just make sure i
remember this quickly
uh you were talking about the fact that
um the high value man is not necessarily
linked to
money and then i think that's where you
would stop before we
left well it's the it's the it's the
thing that
gets under men's skin the most
because but when we but we know it's a
true
we know it's a truism i am sorry
gentlemen i didn't make the rules i
don't make the world
but dr tia-san johnson who teaches black
masculine studies university of
california santa barbara
he's talked about the very one of two cl
one or two courses in the united states
he's looking at 19 and 20 year old women
in the class
sitting next to 19 and 20 year old men
and
these women were telling these young men
that yeah i only want to deal with a
dude making six figures the most and
these guys are realizing that i'm going
to come out with a
degree in accounting i'm not going to
crack that less than 10
or less than 13 depending upon the
number 13 to 10
of the population makes that but if you
ask
consistently whether they want to say it
directly or indirectly
women traditionally want men to
out earn them to be able to pay the
major bills
what i've done is i've actually put a
framework to allow women to actually say
the truth
and more men are upset because the
majority of men don't make that the
median income in the united states for
men is 38
000 dollars okay so i i like what this
conversation's going i think when people
hear you say high value and this is what
women want it almost to women sounds
like you're
i know that's not what you're saying but
to women the way they interpret it is
that they're saying
hearing oh well i'm i'm
going to be with a man who probably
won't make that six figures or more
so therefore my man is not high value um
and it's kind of a tough thing to accept
if you look at your partner like they're
the perfect person for you it's like no
these people still have value so i think
that's where the disconnect is coming is
what i'm making
okay so i had a conversation with a
young lady who lives in the memphis area
and my video is up right now and i think
the title of it is something along the
lines that this happens too often with
modern women
but they don't put they don't they think
about the man they want but they don't
really think about
the practicality of it who is this man
what does he want from a woman
what kind of position is he gonna need
to hold to make the kind of money that i
need to make to kind of have the kind of
lifestyle i want
and as i was getting into the i was
asking
because like you said we had a
conversation before
i am i'm a highly trained interviewer
and a skilled sales person
and i ask questions to reveal things to
the person i'm talking to
and as i'm getting into it she says
something i feel like this is all coming
down to finances i'm like
i'm just asking you questions about the
things you say you want
but we don't want it to come down to
money we want it to come down to
spirituality and god's gonna send me a
husband and if i'm a good man
guess what there are no high-value
homeless men in a woman's mind they may
have value to a society
but in a dating and mating sense not so
much
see this conversation has made a laser
on what women mean about high value
versus what men mean because
it's not just money because if money was
the indicator
all you would need to make is money to
keep her there
you know women queue on many different
things the high estimation of their
their network of friends the network the
society the vision i mean
it's more things than just money so
what tends to happen is folks say well
well
you don't have to make a lot of money to
be high value i know some high value men
ain't worth nothing
yeah take that on the modern dating
scene that may be what you say
but you're trying to go go try to step
to that that eight nine or ten that you
think is an eight nine or ten and
everybody else thinks it's an eight nine
to ten and try to tell her i'm on
fridays and tell her i'm making
dollars a year and see if she decides to
exchange igs with
yeah and i think the most important
thing that people have to remember is
that
just because your partner is not
necessarily high value does not mean
that they're not special to you or not a
wonderful partner or not a wonderful
provider the same way
just because your partner is not
supremely attractive it does not mean
that you don't find them incredibly
attractive or want to bone them every
day
when he uses his lingo he's not talking
about you within the confines of your
relationship he's talking about
individuals within the greater construct
that is a society
one can be great within a dynamic in a
relationship and be the perfect partner
for you
and still not necessarily be a high
value man which i think is fine
i'm going to be a great husband to
someone at some point someday i hope
but that does not mean that i'm
necessarily a high value man as a result
my wife might view me that way no it's
not that's the thing
that's why i don't want to touch on that
that's better more often than anything
else
like the average events video i said
what i was like what is wrong with an
average man that's the question i ask
more often than anything yeah i had a
young lady coming out of college i'm
like
why why can't you just marry the local
plumber she said
instinctively she said no this almost
getting a political science degree
she instinctively said no because what
she associated problem with plumbers
make some great money
right but the reality is my show has
asked women to say what they want and
there's too much
even anecdotal information to just think
this is a coincidence
but i think that's where that's where
the problem is and that's what a
disconnect is for the people
your detractors is that whenever you
talk about one thing
they link it to something else when you
talk about
high value you speak that i mean i think
that's very important because people are
really not
they are basing themselves when they
have conversation on what they think
a word means and not what we're actually
talking about so basically
we could agree on a lot of things but if
you don't have the same
uh the right the right definition of the
words when the words are very important
you're going to be talking about some
other things so you're talking you're
talking about
high value but they think about high
morals
[Music]
i think it's more than that though
preach you know what it is because this
is a concept that he's discussing on a
macro scale meaning he's talking about
society at large
but when people think about dating and
their relationship they think about it
on a micro scale they think about their
interpersonal experiences
so when he says this is what it is for
men they're looking at like well my last
boyfriend wasn't like that but it's not
about that if that makes sense
it's both actually it's really both
because they they
though i feel like the words are
different that the definition of the
words are
off and after that they take it personal
to
their own their own choices and they
think that
when we because even we are sometimes
the victim to more victim
people we have the tractors and they say
the same thing that uh they say to kevin
says most that we don't like black women
that we don't like to do this and that
but we're not it's not necessarily our
views before you you you join back in
that's what i was saying
it's really a depiction of what the
world is out there so if you talk about
the dating world
if you don't see the dating world like
that that's one thing but if
most people see the dating world like
that and you just know that the
dating world is the way it is that
there's there are still roles i don't
necessarily want that but that's
that's out there then well the thing is
i have i talked to an average of five
women a day
for close to 10 months
that's that's well in excess of 250
conversations
but they're more than that it's not see
it's one thing when men are talking
about these things it's easily to
dismiss what i say
you say or whatever when i have a woman
sitting here saying i am
38 years old and i make 80 000 a year
and i ask could you really make a date a
man making 50 000.
the answer comes back well i could if
he's
ambitious if he wants this i'm like no
that's what he's making that's all he's
going to make
he doesn't need to go out and conquer
the world he's a competent man
and the answer comes back when i frame
it in such a way it's like
well no i couldn't deal with that and
i'm like so basically you have you are
reduced men
to either wallets or they're sexual
organs
that's a problem with my in my opinion
that's a problem that modern women have
with modern men
i'd say modern women really don't know
or understand who men are so
and i think talking about being
objectified i'm sorry my show shows that
women
objectify men on a macro level
because if you're sitting here saying
that i
could not date a man who has character
moral ethics
he will be a stepfather to my daughter
and be everything great and wonderful
you would have an egotistical problem
that every time a dollar was spent
80 uh 70 cents of it was coming out of
your quote-unquote pile
that's something that you need to take
up with you because that's not something
a man can fix
i mean i'm we're basically telling men
that you have to be
super human to get just a normal
reasonable
outcome with women and ladies whether
you like it or not
look on your left ring finger is there a
wedding ring of a man that you value
on it if not then and if not and you
desire to be married
or have a relationship of profound
emotional significance or whatever
it's not working
you know i i really resent the idea
that settling is somehow a bad thing
yeah you know i think it comes into this
esoteric idea that people have that like
we're
all amazing and we're all top-notch and
we're all great no there's higher keys
there's
people are better than others in terms
of a greater
greater societal role and and and i
think when people hear the word settling
it's like
i'm going to accept something everyone's
got and men
know this men know that they have to
settle because we know how these
hierarchies work
i knew it right away it was not fair
that my brother could go up to a girl
and get her number instantly and i had
to talk to 10 girls before i could get
one
it's not fair did you have to settle for
being a lieutenant because there were
only so many generals that's a hierarchy
men understand that there's a hierarchy
yeah we understand that that that
you don't see many 30 year old genitals
it takes time
see what gets people with me is
the actual black and white of it the
simplicity of it
i one of my gifts is i can take an
extremely
complex topic and make it really simple
to where it's offensive to it's what
it's really doing
honestly and i focus especially in a uh
i'm a majority christian nation
you ask a lot of women are you a
christian now i'm a christian i'm a
christian
but then you say well are you living
your dating and mating life like a
christian
because i was raised i was baptized to
five raised christians
and it's like well what are we doing
here because
ultimately women don't want to sound
like they're picking a man based upon
his money and i'm like his resource i'm
like well
a thousand years ago women picked a man
based upon
his resources his ability to provide
that was a practical reason
see we have we have changed what men
used to do
to have a woman you had to be able to
protect her provide for her
and protect and provide for your
offspring there was no dollar bills
you didn't have a stash of gold in your
cabin or your hut
or whatever now
what men do has been monetized and done
by society
to where we have really really narrowed
down men to where if he can't do this
this this
i can do bad all by myself i'd rather be
alone so
who's being more shallow ladies is it me
because i say men
want women who are fit feminine and
fabulous women want
cooperative submissive that's what the
men say they want men want women who are
feminine beautiful inspirational
fbi women want men who are confident
intelligent assertive cia
is it me being shallow or is it that
more often than not
women are coming back they say if he's
not this this this this this
i can do bad all by myself i'd rather
not i'd rather have
nothing than to round it back than to
settle
but think about what you're telling
everybody preach about you telling
70 to 80 of men you're just something to
be settled for
i reject that
[Music]
i'm an advocate for my blue collar
brothers i'm an advocate for my military
men
now i'm a white collar man and i've said
it before and i say it again white
collar men ladies wouldn't be crap
without blue-collar men
the men who built this country built
this world get out there use their back
their muscles their label to build the
roads
dig the ditches lay the fiber lay the
pipes do all the stuff that
men like myself do not want to do but it
takes a hell of a longer to become
somebody like me it is easier for
somebody to go become an electrician
a plumber a hvac technician a roofer and
become their own entrepreneur their own
business own their own stuff
to provide it it's so much harder to do
it this way
it just looks better to you because you
can go back to your
friends and say i got a doctor i got a
finance guy i got a suction so i got a
lawyer i got this
but if you say i got a plumber
that plumber could be a
multi-millionaire a hell of a lot faster
than these so-called lawyers
with all this student loan debt so check
yourselves before you get mad at me
um i'm going to move this
to something a little bit different
when we talk about hypergamy and we talk
about the fact that uh you know people
are general well
specifically are hypergamous do you feel
like this trend
is starting to go out the window to some
degree or it's lessening to some degree
due to the fact that one
uh women make more money than before and
despite them making more money they
still maintain some level of hypergamy
that's still present
but do you feel like as women continue
to succeed in the workforce and that
continues and men
as the trend looks right now are
starting to fall behind more and more
do you feel like eventually women are
either going to have to accept the fact
that they're gonna have to drop the
hypergamy
or do you feel like society's gonna have
to shift uh
no the short answer is evolutionary
biology is what it is
we have evolved to be this way what's
happening
is the petro principle is going into
overdrive
consolidating on women are a hypergamous
by evolutionary design
and i don't want to belabor that point
but the research is there
so what means is the top 20
of men is going to need now i need to be
the top 10 percent the top 10 is the top
five the top five the top one and i ask
ladies all the time all right ladies
what kind of man do you want what does
he want from a woman
and if the kind and caliber man you want
by definition
are statistically and not rare
twenty percent ten percent five percent
one percent
are you prepared to share as women did
back in the day with
with kubla khan genghis khan kings
nobility and royalty of old
ladies like it or not a thousand years
ago women shared high value men
they would rather [ __ ] they would rather
be the duke's mistress
than to be the butchers or the other
other cobblers
or wife i don't make human beings this
is how we come
uh but i'm going to push back um so
apparently the share of american women
earning more than
uh their husbands or co-editing partners
has increased steadily over the last
years
hitting 28 as of 2017. so there's been a
steady increase
of relationships where women are with
men
who are not earning as much as them and
that is continuing upward
now uh this data i'm trying to fix the
data doesn't include generational
breakdown
which means for younger groups it
probably
is higher what do you say to that trend
that seems to be developing which
go ahead okay so
i don't i'd have to look at the number
but i would also say
when men and women are doing the same
kind of jobs men are out earning women i
mean men and women earn roughly the same
amount of money
doing the same job but if what you're
saying is women are starting to out earn
men i don't really have to see where
that's coming from because
men go into the jobs that tend to be
higher risk higher pay
science engineering technology immense
stem sure
you don't tend to see the largest
employers of our
especially the black community the
largest employer of women federal
government
and retail these are not careers these
are jobs so even if
even the net of it you look at what
percentage of women are earning six
figures or more
i want to say it's less than six percent
men are still twice as much so
where it matters wherever the things are
trending at the end of the day
men are still the workers and the
builders because we choose different
careers
and we want to talk about this overall
equality and equality we're gonna have
to start getting real granular
when women going to start becoming going
out to alaska
digging the ditches building the
buildings doing the dangerous jobs
because the the jobs you're talking
about there may be increasing in that
sector
but we had a she session in the last uh
quarter
2 million jobs are lost here in the
states and 98
of that were from women we had one month
where 880 000
jobs were lost from women alone
so i don't know where that stats coming
from but here
american women are starting to realize
real quick that i cannot get to from
here to the end of my life
successfully and live the kind and
calorie of life and have the lifestyle i
want
on one solitary income
sorry a little malfunction with preacher
yeah keep going
so my my ultimate point is this
the notion that women are this emergent
and sisters are doing it for themselves
uh do they want to is the question
and most most women when either ask them
do you
want what percentage of the family bill
do you want to have to pay significant
bills after you're pregnant
inevitably that 99 of the time the
answer comes back is no
and when now they've learned that i'm
going to ask that question they've
learned how to kind of not answer my
answer and i was like okay well how
about this
what percentage of the financial family
how what percentage of the financial
family load
do you want you have to carry for a
lifetime
that's when the beatboxing starts uh
well
and inevitably it comes back as
something less than 30 percent
10 20 25 okay
well if you only want to carry 10 to 25
and maybe 30 percent of the family house
that means the bulk 70 percent has to be
carried by your spouse
how many children do you want where do
you want to live how much money would a
man need to make to cover
80 70 of this lifestyle then that women
come back to the world
this sounded like it's all about money
it's what you want
yeah well i mean you know money is just
a it's just a substitute for
essentially security exactly and i mean
you know there's nothing wrong with
wanting security if i'm going to raise a
family i want security i want my kids to
know that they're going to have their
hobbies taken care of
to me a woman wanting financial security
and a partner does not make
her lesser than i don't look at women
who i think you're normal
yeah and if you don't if you don't care
about how much money your partner makes
and to me you're not ready for marriage
you're not ready for a family i would
find it very suspicious
if a woman didn't take it to serious
consideration how much money
because denim tells me one you're not
ready and two you don't have
any intentions of starting a family at
least not in a safe way
i think what it also says is women start
to understand that these numbers are
very finite it starts we all play
musical chairs as a kid
and as as the parameters start to get
tighter and tighter
they start looking around and saying
wait a minute there are only so many of
these men
and if everybody i did one show where
women from boston
to oregon that's from east coast to west
coast here
all described the same demographic man
all all of them and i'm like you all
from one coast to another want the same
man
only one of you can get him so that
means that other
four of you can't or if you want him are
you willing to share and
so so what it ultimately comes down that
says ladies if you really want this kind
of man
what are you prepared to do are you
prepared well that was spicy
i was just like some people this guy and
they just like
and that's what it comes down to a lot
of women in the west haven't been told
they've been told that they're the prize
and the man is supposed to
go out and become superman and then lay
the world down at their feet like
you don't you don't you you don't
believe in happy wife happy happy life i
believe that's a
disaster and i've said that i said this
on my show naming a society
who have placed the needs and wants of
the women ahead of the men
that has been productive competitively
successful and
no woman has been it you can't see
we haven't but but i want to just push
back on that notion that you just said i
agree with you that there aren't
societies like that but we also have to
admit that we are in a completely
different time than we've ever been
it is no longer a society where women
have to constantly worry about their
physical safety like it used to be
before you know where getting pregnant
out of wedlock was a death sentence
today you can still strive and still be
successful in
a personal life whereas you know if you
take it 150 years well if you get
pregnant out of wedlock that could be
the end of your life
right so we need to be physical safety
what are you referring to though
well i mean look look i'm not saying
people don't get attacked today but it's
nothing like it used to be
if we're if we're being very candid the
crime rate
even compared to 40 years ago is
completely different than it is today
and if you go back 100 150 years the
mortality rate thanks to medicine all
these things i agree you don't have to
worry
so so when we're saying like what
societies i'm like well societies that
were before us lived a completely
different existence
where we are now is unparalleled women
being in the workforce
means that we cannot compare how we're
living today to how what things used to
be
um as an example well what we can do is
like and
that safety thing i would i would say as
somebody who was alive 40 years ago
uh women were far safer back then
because we had neighborhoods
you could leave i'm sorry where i came
from people slept with their door open
women were far safer back 50 years ago
that's why when in this country when
they go make america great again
typically what people want to admit or
not they go back to the 50s
and that's where the height of jim crow
segregation uh everything else all those
racial inequality but what we did have
was something else
see what we don't want to have is we
want a society
where men and women are equals we want
and far too many people want equal
outcomes no hierarchy but then at the
end of the day men are still expected to
do traditional roles
the building and administering society
but don't tell me what to do
yeah um on the on the idea of it being
safer
maybe 40 50 years ago i agree that maybe
in within a neighborhood you might feel
that way
because of certain factors but there's
like statistically speaking
crime was crazy you know as little as 20
20 25 years ago today 20 25 years ago
was the height of the crack epidemic too
so
i mean we have to be careful see why i'm
careful about that kind of stuff is
because oftentimes
my detractors will come back and say
well wait you want to go back in a day
when women were slaves and they could be
beaten and they could be this and i'm
like
i call that the color purpling of
america you can go back and research the
color purple
and the impact it was predicted to
possibly have on the black community
we're still suffering
from what alex walker wrote there and
that did just
it just did not happen mr did not exist
on every block more often than not
you had a different world and i was
alive during this time i'm like these
worlds
that have been mythologized were not
true
okay do you so so this is my question to
you do you believe
that your perception of this is based on
reality or do you believe because you
lived in a time where social media
wasn't present where
crime from everywhere wasn't always
being sent directly to your door
that i've got i believe that we have to
be careful what we call
crime okay because we've been
we've mentioned infant mortality birth
and then we talked up
and talked about violence against women
we have to be very clear
because i understand one thing more than
anything else
we this has been
how do you how do you how do you talk
about something where there's no data
for it and you have to go from people's
recollection and anecdotal experience
well
i don't know anybody who's above 45 who
will tell you that the world is safer
today
from a property standpoint from a
personal standpoint than it is today
we gotta we gotta sorry sorry just
repeat uh
safer today compared to what to win then
back then back in the 60s and 50s
you got to lock everything today i mean
locks on doors used to be a chain just
and people didn't do that you
these people literally slept with their
front doors open
screen right right but my question my
question that is
it's not because people are taking these
safety precautions that things are
necessarily more dangerous
what i'm trying to say is because of the
world that we live in because we
assimilate
constant information from everywhere it
clouds our perception
of what the situation really is so for
example you have people today be like
this is one of the most dangerous times
in history i'm like uh sorry you go back
20 30 years ago the crime levels are on
you
are not comparable they're not even
close to comparable so that's why i
question whether or not like i get what
you're saying in regards to people felt
like they could open their doors but
that's not necessarily an indication of
whether or not the times were so number
15 or 20 years ago was 15 that was that
was still two thousands
oh yeah and it was vague but i'm talking
about the world prior to 1985
which is where a lot of a lot of young
guys don't get because the world prior
to crack
was a different world there were no
gangs
like we have now there was no
this didn't exist this virulent drug
trade this is where you got the scar
faces
the movie the scarface the cocaine
cowboys all that stuff that did not
exist
so what came along with the drug trade
after the
the breaking of the uh the industrial
base of america
the the the unionizing of the midwest
when all the jobs were shipped out of
the seas when the factories the gms the
fords and everything else
left suburbia that made it to where you
could have a high school diploma
and still provide for a family of four
left
we decimated we decimated the middle
class look at what reaganomics did to
this country
right after the 70s in in stagflation
wages have been flat there's an economic
reason why crime has been what it
is and then the illicit drug trade came
in to make an economy in these depressed
areas and with the drugs
came crime but if the drugs weren't
there
or if you legalize the drug trade take
away the incentive
for the turf wars and everything else
people are still people
so that's why i'm careful about these
stats because they will get used and
misinterpreted
to make demonize one time over another
yeah from 85 to 2085 to the mid 90s we
had from the 80s to the mid-90s
we had crack and then after that we
jumped right into a little epidemic of
heroin and then we got into the
carjackings and all that other stuff
and it was it was even typified in the
movies we go from nwa
to the ghetto boys the two live crew to
all that stuff
then we get into the movies uh colors
and minister society and what was the
last one
belly where are all these where are
these where all these movies now
where are all these movies about these
urban crime dramas where people are
getting carjacked
uh they don't exist because people don't
live like that anymore
you gotta be real careful with that one
in my opinion so so you you feel like
okay all right well you know what listen
i think honestly going into the whole
crime thing was not something i wanted
right here we can we can but i mean
that's just
saying that i'm not i can't i guess we
can have an exchange of this but i just
know how
people take would take a sound bite and
say yeah see
we were we are safer it was more
dangerous back then i'm like well
i can understand from a statistical
standpoint but
i'm talking about when did human beings
ever work together and it's when men and
we we were safer how about that i think
we can both agree on this
we were safer when we had nuclear
families in neighborhoods
again i would agree that generally
within a community standpoint you could
feel that way because you had a sense of
but i when i look at what safety means
for me it's not a matter of like what
people feel
for me it's like what do the numbers
reflect i can understand your
perspective you haven't lived through it
and like what you may have seen
but when i'm looking at fbi stats and
what they felt like was the worst time
for crime and things like that
that's what i consider a time of safety
or not if crime is not at an all-time
high or if it's not extremely prevalent
then for me that's
by definition but you also got to
understand this fbi
stats they're coming from heavily
populated areas you live in where
toronto
no no i live in i live in montreal at
the moment it's still a heavy populated
area but yeah right
but most of the united states is not
that right
so you respect what happens in new york
versus what happens in oklahoma city are
two different things
okay and when you have neighborhoods
where there's a husband
and a father a husband and wife there's
typically gonna be somebody at home to
watch the property
when there's more than one child there's
going to be people around when your
neighbors
lived when the johnsons lived over here
and the jenkins lived over here
people didn't move you understood who we
have a transient society people are
moving
people most people don't even know who
their neighbors to the right left and
front and back or anymore versus when i
was growing up people knew everybody on
the block
three blocks over right it's hard to
come into that
area and do crime okay so so my question
to you is do you feel like things
in suburban areas are more dangerous
today
because you you basically said you know
the reason why those crime stats were so
elevated was because they weren't
i think that people feel less safe today
because they're less connected to other
people
okay that's fair and i would agree with
you on that point i agree that
people today feel extremely less safe i
just my only question is whether that
actually translates into real danger
i'm constantly seeing a lot of
fear-mongering which i honestly feel
often times is unjustified
you know it's kind of like when a
natural disaster happens everyone's like
it's the end of the world well you know
what the earthquake happened in taipei
i don't know why you care just because
it showed up in your facebook feed that
doesn't necessarily mean that terrible
things are coming your way
but i think the way we assimilate
information makes us
more primed to believe and then you
compound that with the fact that we are
disassociated from the people around us
it makes us feel alone and we only
assimilate negative things
so i think i think that's the mixture of
stuff that i feel like is is making us
feel more unsafe than we
actually are at times which if you round
it back to where we started
the chatter online around me all this
negative
when i walk out there if i can actually
have
a little drone following me people will
be amazed at what happens in the real
world
and that's real what happens online
people can say
lots of things but in the world how can
i walk
out in atlanta and where all the hate
i'm supposed to have and
i should be walking around with security
versus hey man let me buy you a drink
let me buy you some
men you know what you know what jesus
gave me an idea i think i'm gonna
hire me a camera man having fun he just
just to show you how
how good it is yeah because because
granted when we
are alone when we're we're not attached
to anybody
and especially when the car have been
dependent or the when the thing happened
we're all attached to these things and
we're watching
we don't get outside so when i had my
men in training
seminars before coronavirus the first
thing i would tell guys who came in from
around the country
learning how to be the best version of
themselves of like gentlemen the first
thing i would say is life
happens outside number two life is about
people
see that's what we really haven't got
down to men and women
are just human beings people and we are
forgotten how to relate
we have forgotten the value we actually
have for one another
the practical value it's come down to
things that are just
wants and desires because we've
eliminated the quote-unquote need
what happened to uh what happened to uh
uh priest had to drop out over something
and
he couldn't announce it because i think
you're in the middle of talking so you
just want to slip out quietly so
i gotta give me a 30 seconds i'll be
right back
yeah not an issue not sure um while we
wait for kevin to come back we're going
to be transitioning to other topics and
you know for everyone's watching at home
understand when i challenge him on ideas
it's not because i necessarily disagree
i just think the only way to have robust
discussions
is to have people who question what may
be false in your ideas so when you guys
are watching like oh my god abba hates
the man or
i was just saying things sometimes you
gotta go deeper into the topic and it
actually makes the other person be able
to expand
and to showcase their ideas in more
flavorful ways that's how you have
really good discussions anybody can sit
here and be a giant yes man and that's
boring
that's boring the way you expand on
ideas the way you make people better and
you make yourself better
is by challenging what they're saying
ask them yo what would you do in this
circumstance
okay based off these statistics how do
you feel
because if we're just here to agree
because a person across from you
is respected then what you end up
creating is dogma
and people walk around thinking this
[ __ ] never stinks because nobody ever
tells them that it might
right so that's how we hold each other
accountable i got more stuff i want to
challenge kevin on
because i think in doing so not only
does it
give you guys an opportunity to see
these ideas challenged but it also helps
me
and it helps everybody else to um
to see these ideas what's that
challenging wave
yeah yeah and it helps everyone to just
see how strong these ideas actually
are so that's the only way we have good
discussions you know if it's not me
it's going to be some random person who
can't articulate their point and then
nothing ever gets done right so
that's why we do these things they're
important
they're important because you know study
look if you're going to put an idea out
front you need to be able to stand on it
and let people know why you believe what
you believe and more often than not
people can disagree on the idea good
people can disagree
but it's all about the why i think i
recall did you say you
are you from uh you know grew up muslim
yes no
i grew up in a muslim family and i grew
up in ethiopia for a large section of my
life yes
so i will say
that the word patriarchy
masculinity have become so
um negatively marketed
to where i don't think people understand
how we have diminished our society
as if when you had a mom and dad in the
house
and men in the neighborhood that it was
a
dangerous place no your daughter could
play in the front yard
without worrying about somebody
abducting him
the world i can't lived in children we
got on our bike
we had to be out of the house um out of
the house by
uh by 10 a.m you had to be out i i'm
still 30. so i i did experience that
but i mean but because you know why
because mom and him she was cleaning the
house put the oj's on smoking these
cigarettes
you got to watch your looney tunes eat
your cereal and you had to get out on
the bike so what did we do
i got with you and preach and we rode
the neighborhood we took the dogs out we
went to the clubhouse
we went climb trees we did all this
stuff and we had to be home what before
the porch light for the street light
came on
kids weren't getting abducted people
were people were safe
and the thing is because we had
something we actually had people who
cared about one another
knocking on your neighbor's door to say
hey but man i'm out of sugar man you
guys are shaking we'll be like
who are you you know me i'm your
neighbor
now we move and have this society to
where
everybody has their own little world and
we got more friends like this we got
more friends online than we do in person
how about that i damn
no yeah so it's it's not hard for human
beings to feel unsafe because
in a prison the worst thing you can do
is put somebody in what solitary
confinement most of us live in solitary
empire and per in our public
yeah i mean i would i would be inclined
to agree i think we
again this is a completely unparalleled
time we've never had like
i feel like the internet's changed
things in ways we'll never quite
understand until
another 100 years like you know the way
our minds work the
even the ideas of nationalism are
starting to recede as we're connecting
with people all across the world
but also we're losing things we're
losing connections to our neighbors the
people across the street
and i don't think we're able to quite
yet measure the impacts of that and it's
not even just on our social
like it's also on our relationship
dynamics the idea that we're starting
everything online there's no
point of reference i don't know any of
your friends you don't know any of my
friends you know there's something to
that when you're in a dating sphere
that makes you beholden to a community
and how you behave with people
it was very difficult for me to flash my
penis to you if everyone you knew and
knew everyone i knew there was a certain
level of decorum that was necessary
so i'm inclined to agree that um things
are drastically different at the moment
uh for some reason things are frozen let
me just see that okay all right i just
human evolution
we i mean we are undergoing the largest
change in human evolution
since the gutenberg printing press we
have not evolved to have
global reach this is why
and it comes back into the dating
environment men and women the
the deal used to be a man would give his
non
his time attention resources uh
for a woman's sexual attention and that
used to be
shared in the context of a committed
relationship typically a marriage
and they would get there they would get
those things from one another
but when you have a world that where
all women can just be online and get
attention from men everywhere yup
it has an impact upon the the evolution
our brains have developed developed the
way we have so what does that do
well where if you may have gotten your
your validation your things from the men
in your
your life then the men and your family
and men around you it's still very small
but then if you multiply that by a
factor of thousands
millions what does it mean when you get
a post
and it has a million likes on it but
when i talk to these
very same instagram models and beautiful
women
offline and i don't want to say some of
the names but
multiple millions of subscribers are
followers
yeah they're and they and guess what
their breath stinks
they go to bathroom mistakes and they're
still having the same
issues yeah that we all are having
we are disconnected and distrusted and
we distrust each other
no i mean it's a culture everything
because you have to especially for us
think about where we're at now you have
to move in a certain way because every
time
human beings don't know how to handle
all that no no
well i mean what you talked about in
regards to that kind of imbalance
is uh it's a basic tenet of supply and
demand
because there's such a supply for women
now that they're being online and
there's
you know so much demand from them in
terms of like yo people really want what
they have
of course it's hard i think i read
something it was a really interesting uh
little piece but it basically said that
um i'm not i'm just read it off
hopefully i can put up on screen
but it said the um
the genie coefficient for the tinder
economy is
0.58 which means that it has a higher
inequality than 95 percent of the
world's national economies
meaning what women can get out of online
dating versus men
the inequality is so vast between the
two it's more inequality than most
countries
economy so it just goes to show that
these kinds of concepts are affecting us
on uh
on on a grand scale and when you talk
about the the effect of us being
disconnected from each other i agree
with you 150
i think i think sociologists and
scientists are going to be studying that
and looking into that for
for a long time these these
this sector right now i believe that
matter of fact i know for a fact that
my show is being watched by a lot of
people
in some very high up places for the data
i've been contacted by some of these
places and the thing is
why would it be there if it's just this
negative
toxic that's
what makes the viral video moments that
that's what makes the entertainment but
the education the
the actual connections every day i'm
getting at least
10 emails from women saying like i was
out yesterday a young sister
big hoop earrings shout out to you know
you are you had a blue mask on earrings
stuck inside she's like
you changed my life
i'm like huh this is what happens more
often than not
black women come to me you changed my
life
i got emails from listening to my words
come out of another woman's mouth makes
me
understand how unreasonable i was being
to my husband
i am a better wife a better mother a
better sister
my current and future generations thank
you i'll put that up against any of my
critics and detractors who
aren't really coming at this thing from
a sense of good faith why are most of
the people are coming at you guys are
they coming at it from a sense
of good faith really wanting to
understand or is it really just a matter
of
something i mean you know i think you
can kind of tell the difference if
people
have substantive arguments and they're
making an effort to explain why they
feel the way that they feel then i think
it's easy to
try to assimilate what they're trying to
say but i've had the similar experience
as you you know i've spoken enough times
on my channel about the fact that women
can be very physically abusive and yeah
the
thing about that is that i said this
before
is that they're not necessarily evil
people they just never been told to be
accountable for the physical violence
that they engage in
you know even when i say stuff like you
know within the relationship in our
marriage it's like
50 of the violence is initiated by women
that doesn't mean that women
are just as effective or just as
dangerous as men or nothing like that
but they do initiate a lot and when i
say these things they get this push back
against me because they're like
how dare but i'm like i'm not saying
anything that's unhealthy i'm just
saying don't put your hands on people
and you guys do it a lot
and i've had experiences where women
have come up to me and said you know
what i've actually done some of the
stuff that you
said and hearing you talk about it and
you showing like video footage of like
women doing that has like helped me
realize i'm like that's good
you know we all need that certain level
of account of you i think what the issue
is is
again i think when it comes to certain
behaviors we allow people to do as they
please so when you come on the scene
and you say hey ladies this is what
you're doing well they've never heard
that message right
when jordan peterson comes on the scene
and says clean your room well they've
never been told
to take accountability for the mess that
they're creating so i think people
like the idea of accountability they
just don't necessarily get told they
need
their idea of accountability for others
but let's look at the movie captain
marvel
and the parts they cut out of the movie
where she actually assaulted a man stole
his motorcycle
and rode away uh we can even go to
captain america where the woman who paid
plays uh what was her name
uh his his love interest whatever
hey i don't yeah whatever she he was
coming out of the
out of the new vita with this new body
shirt off and she said that the first
time i'd seen him without his shirt on
and in the movie she reaches out and
grabs his pack
there's a clip going online right now
with millions of views talking about
that's the first time i've seen him with
his shirt off so i just reached out
there and just
grabbed his boob and this woman sitting
next to another woman who's a devout
uh equality feminist womanist and all
the women are just laughing i'm like
now wait a minute if a man had just
reached out and grabbed a woman's boob
see we accept we accept one-way
uh aggression from women but you're not
supposed to even
speak your mind as a man to where your
words
your thoughts are now aggressive
to where we're policing tone and
everything else i'm like okay well
how do we expect to have a society where
men and women get along
when only one person is allowed to be
fully human
when when i will say something i'm going
to use tomorrow
men women's women's past is used to
mythologize them
if a woman had a troubled past or had to
overcome things that's part of her
origin story but far too often a man's
past
is used to demonize him
and then if you're a man of color it's
used to villainize you
i want it to be humanizing so where we
can all realize that we have something
that we all have something to offer one
another men have something to offer this
world
women have something out for this world
they're different things
they are they're they're they they rank
differently
but they're eq they're important and
that's how we can get back to the whole
notion of relationship
where women can start holding men and a
value of esteem outside of their ability
to produce
resources and good things in the bedroom
what else and vice versa
because i think that's the biggest
breakdown between all of us we know how
to come together on a swipe right
hook up economy we don't know how to
interact with each other outside the
bedroom
that's why we so many people tend to
cycle through this modern dating economy
because there's a lot of accusation
there's a lot of acquisition there's no
keeping
you say that marriage is often times the
goal
um why is that very narrowly i'm now
i want to transition when you start
talking about high value men
not for everybody okay
marriage is often times ago for women
who call into my show
and women tend to want to have
to marry a man who is in this
high value category um
that's just a statement of fact that's
what most women tend to want they want
to commit a relationship with one man
who can provide for them
their offspring and their children why
they want it
that's a different story um now today
marriage for the average guy
is an extremely risky proposition
because
with the advent of no fault divorce
and the family court system written for
a 1940s 50s world in a 2020 environment
you don't often find men who walk away
from a divorce in a better financial
position
oftentimes they're worse probably
destroyed
so that's if neither if neither has
children
if you complicate that further by a
woman coming to the
possible marriage with another man's
child it further
complicates that i think women need to
understand
what they're asking for the rank and
final man
now unfortunately i had to make a
decision
as an image consultant anything i do i
don't speak for
the the average guy would never need to
hire an image consultant
or what i do so while i can understand
um what they're going through my target
audience is men in the top
who want to be in the top 20 top 10 of
men
and and the women who want to be in the
top 20 top 30 of women
and for those people marriage is often a
goal because
after uh when you with a divorce rate in
this country are better than 51 52
when you surpass a net income or gross
income of what 200
275 000 that number drops to 20 percent
people with more couples with more
resources tend to find tend to have
lower divorce rates and find reasons to
stay together
differently than their counterparts
so what would you say for folks who are
not in within that tax bracket i
understand that your services are
probably geared more towards people on
the higher level income but for the
people
who you know are hovering around 50 000
or you know not necessarily in that high
end
what would you say should marriage still
be a goal in that regards
well again i for men or for women
those are different things should go and
go through both
for men i mean i i don't make
no no directly no because i i don't make
the current environment
okay if i can have women from
all right from from any race
look and say i want a man who's learning
twice what i'm making three times or
more
how do i look at a man who's making 50
000 a year
and tell him you're going to be able to
have an effective male
frame and a masculine position in a
relationship
when when most women say they want a man
who's earning twice as much as you
no matter how we like to slice it it
comes down to finances and resources
because that's the number one reason
people state for divorce
okay so no it's not like it was
wages are flat and everything else but
for women
women have still evolved the way they've
evolved they're still
wanting to have in a marriage with one
man
to produce their child with one man so
they don't have to continue to do this
mating and dating dance in their 40s and
50s
i cannot square that circle i don't have
the power
we are in the times we are so the way
the way if you if marriage is a goal for
a woman
here's the net net of it i am sorry
ladies but this is gonna hurt
the kind and caliber of men you want
earning the kind of money you're talking
about
they want something from a woman they
tend to want her to be
fit feminine friendly cooperative
submissive
childless so they are
free to want what they want they had to
make themselves that
how much how old does a man typically
need to be
to earn the kind of money you're talking
about men hit their financial stride
from 45 to 55.
so if you want a man earning these
things and you got to be honest
do you expect it for a 28 year old guy
how can he do it age gap dating
uh going into the geography or the area
where these men are and then
you still got to compete with the women
who are around them
and that's what's frustrating for so
many folks because like
women in this conversation know
the outcome they want the question is
can they get it
in a form that they are willing to
accept because many want that outcome
from one man and then i'm not going to
go down that other path because that
open a whole nother can of worms
oh yeah you don't want to talk about uh
you know what i mean concubines and all
that good stuff
well hey see and i would tell you this
there was a that's not something i do
but
seriously and for a man i think you make
yourself the best version of yourself
and you decide what kind of life you
want to have but you got to realize that
especially in the west
if you're making if you're going to have
a position where you're or your
potential spouse is not going to be
going to be working and making our money
that comes with a different calculus the
the traditional male
female gender roles um
aren't necessarily going to map as
nicely and easily as they did but here's
what i ultimately believe
i ultimately believe that it always
comes down to the same thing
one man and one woman can decide to
hammer out a deal
my mother did my mother lived one way
her life and then at 50 years old she
decided to do
what she knew arguably was the best
outcome and from that point she had a
husband for the next 20 some odd years
so and lived a different caliber of life
but that
requires settling
making a practical pragmatic decision
not disney fantasy love so
and that's what it used to be people
didn't fall in love a thousand years ago
500 years ago you married for practical
reasons i need this
i need that i was just having that
conversation i literally
just before we had this conversation
today i feel like this western concept
and this obsession with love as if it's
like the
hallmark of what stabilizes a
relationship the amount of people who
are still in love with their
exes or their you know you know divorced
wives or whatever they're still in love
but they just can't make it work it's
one of the
poorest things to base a the longevity
and the possibility of a relationship
working
um and i think i think that's one thing
that we have to learn to unadopt because
i think we've romanticized the union of
a man and a woman
and made it all about love this
amorphous can you even define love
i'm telling everybody to find love they
can't define it they say it's commitment
loyalty the next person says it's a
feeling
the next person said oh it's a spark i'm
like i don't know what none of that [ __ ]
means
how do you want me to base myself on a
moving cloud
you know that's what it feels like i go
for respect
i go for respect more than anything else
and if you ever watch this series marco
polo on netflix
take kublai khan and take his primary
wife that's pretty much what you're
gonna have that's the ideal situation
for many high-value men
and women uh he's on his purpose and
path and she understands his purpose and
path and they're working together
because the notion of a highly a
productive competitive
high value attractive loyal
alpha male type is a female fantasy and
notion
because they go out and slay the dragon
kill the minotaur bring back all the
meat and they laid in front of your feet
ladies
and g no it's much more like robert
baratheon
i'm sorry it's much more like robert
but then you get into well you mean i
have to accept infidelity or cheating
and such and so forth i'm like now yeah
i just need to make some rules of
engagement up front like
most people who in that tax bracket
they make rules and most people
that's another thing most people don't
know folks in these upper impact bracket
they don't know that out in these
suburbs that this person they they have
rules of engagement
no outside babies no divorce no no
children
no don't make no outside babies don't
bring their own diseases don't embarrass
me in public
so now that's the third railing forever
there's a third reel
hey man that's a big one you gotta you
gotta do a whole two hours on just that
one
well trust me it's coming especially
with everything that's been going on the
last couple of three four days but the
thing is
there used to be a time where women
understood the nature of
men males and what i'm hearing far
often like i i when i did that video
with a three-on-one debate the notion of
fairness
what that what that video showed is far
too many modern women
really do not understand the nature of
the very men that they want they want
women like that woman want men to
operate
like women and it's like well no
men operate like lions you're a lioness
i can't rewire human evolution in
biology
so this is where we come back in this
whole moralistic play trying to
overlap you know this moral of that more
and i will say this being raised in the
bible belt
trying to legislate morality is a
fantasy
oklahoma tattooing was illegally illegal
until in 2020 so people went down
to texas to get tattoos beer you could
only get 3.2 alcohol so people when they
wanted real beer had to drive to texas
all it did was it made texas a lot of
money
people are going when you leave people
alone
leave people alone as they show
in the netherlands people sort ourselves
nicely
when people are left alone men tend to
sort themselves into science engineering
technology and math some of them more
dangerous more
uh careers like that women tend to sort
themselves into the sciences
nursing you know uh
i don't wanna say social work with
things that are much more community or
related but but what we want is
you know proponents want these women
over here you paid with these men over
here
i'm sorry these jobs over here have more
usefulness to society
i did a broadcast about you know with
one woman
talking about if we thanos snap the
world about survival
and i looked bear grylls island number
two season two
and i basically showed that you know
far too many women don't really
understand how the
world is laid out you don't understand
the infrastructure the road the power
system the grids the water
the fire saying i don't need a man
it's a nice notion but if there's a bump
at your door the first thing you're
gonna do is call 9-1-1
hoping a man shows up yeah yeah i mean
i've always
vehemently rejected the notion that uh
you know i don't need a man i always
thought
like who do you think you know built
everything around you in the same token
like
you know we need each other and i think
kind of accepting that that kind of like
arrogance of i don't need anybody we
don't need each other it's just uh
it's divisive and it's uh it's untrue uh
throughout human history
you know um i had some really great
clips from
old stuff that you did that i thought
was really interesting points that i'd
like to hear you expand on
i don't know if you could tune into the
live stream but i actually play for
everyone else to be able to hear as well
and i'll just play them for the live
stream real quick so let me know when
you're good
[Music]
but yeah basically these are clips that
you did while you were talking to men
and men voiced some things to you
and um you had a rebuttal that i thought
was really interesting
but it cut so i was that hold on
yeah not initially not you uh and i
thought when you had this discussion it
was it was a great insight into
i want to say this it was a great
insight into
things that i think men need to hear but
don't often get talked about especially
not in the uh
the the the manosphere per se um so just
let me know when you're good and i'll
play it okay so here's uh here's a clip
right here
what about those of us that require
diversity i found marriage and one woman
to be incredibly boring
i might remarry when and older but am
only 32.
there you go you're 32. what's gonna
happen when you're 50.
how much [ __ ] do you need man but i'll
tell you what
you'll get old real quick 34 is probably
already getting pretty damn old
because it sounds like you've never had
a loving relationship with a woman you
never had a woman rub your head and say
it's gonna be all right
and never had a woman you see guys
who've never had a woman's love
you're missing a lot even though even
the crazy stuff they want to see in
these spaces
fbi women beautiful women who are
feminine and inspirational
provide a hell of a lot more than just
vagina
pam that was a great clip um i'll let
you finish if you haven't finished start
going
the net of it was
men who have not had a their quote
unquote sexual
feel think that life is going to just be
a non-stop
acquisition of new women
and it's not i mean there comes there's
a relationship between a man and a woman
that we're always that that supersedes
the bedroom and i think that's the
problem we don't
value what each of us brings to
uh outside of that this is why
you look at people when they map up when
we look over at celebrities
um if if having all these multiple
millions and billions
this meant you could have concubines or
whatever why don't they have them
because most people don't want that
and i would say this number two number
one number one number two men who are
really on their purpose how
you're busy all the time yup
i'm busy all the time we the first time
we physically spoke was in this live
stream because we are so
damn gun busy yup map that over
to when you have you know five years
from now and your business has evolved
you don't have time to be managing all
these new relationships just for what
an orgasmic release nah you know that's
that's an interesting thing because
there's a misconception that because i
do this youtube stuff and because i have
more access therefore i'm indulging
but it's exactly the opposite it was
before i was involved in my purpose and
in my work
on a full-time basis that i was actually
wasting my time looking left right
center
and it's today that i actually am
you know as sexually inactive as humanly
possible and people say how can that be
you have all this abundance i'm like
well to do that with me and i would take
away from the things that really matter
to me to be able to provide for my
friends and family to work full-time and
grow this business
to be able to make sure that i meet my
obligations to my business partner there
are things
that i value far more than like what you
said the orgasmic release
and so when i talk about settling down i
just don't talk about it as like oh i
want a family i want this it's also a
matter of like
i can't afford to be out here in these
streets because to be out here in these
streets is not only a risk to my
business
but it's also a risk to my mental
well-being to lose my purpose in life
would cost me far too much
and it's very very difficult
to be a player and to be a hyper
successful businessman
yes and that make it work and it's not
something i can do
i've tried it it was miserable and so
when i tell people man like yes be out
these streets okay fine
but recognize eventually it has to stop
it's not because i'm blue peeled
it's because of the idea that i know
you're going to give up things that
matter far more than that and maybe you
could
share your perspective well when i would
yes i mean the short answer is yes look
i look at guys in the nfl and nba who
don't have the benefit of having to
[Music]
work like we did per se they work in a
different environment
but where can you make yourself
competent and getting
uh these opportunities you realize where
you came from
and how rare it is you don't want to go
back
and taking the time to try to chase
women is a disservice to you your
purpose and even the women because
this will crumble this will fall and and
it's so sad to see guys in the nfl after
the nfl
with kids here kids there money falling
apart doing
now they're now they're on fix my life
or whatever
um look
it's easy for me to say if you haven't
had enough success the first thing i do
is i go out and slay a bunch
trust me no sir no sir
um even with with the access i have
enough is enough you want what you want
and that's why my private life i keep it
very
very quiet mm-hmm i only deal with a
certain
certain caliber woman because
it's already stressful enough to be me
you know how that goes in front of the
camera
and and and people are always looking
for something to
expose you about or this or that and
it's like you know what
i'm on my purpose i'm doing what i need
to do because i have an opportunity
that i don't want to waste so many guys
don't have this and this can be a
generational uh blessing
if i manage the opportunity correctly
and
at the end of the day you know i don't
if you've ever sat with older people
i never really sat with an older man in
his late 70s 80s he's like man i wish
i'd got laid more
that's not what they say they regret the
things they blew or the opportunities
they missed
so yeah yeah when i speak about male
promiscuity i think people oftentimes
misinterpret what i'm saying
i don't think that going on having sex
necessarily is inherently a bad thing
what i'm saying is that all that time
you're investing in constantly trying to
seek out women and constantly doing that
if it's the only
or it's the majority of your focus in
your life you're missing out on
something that's too important which is
finding that purpose
finding where you need to go in your
lane in order to feel a
fulfill a truly fulfilled life because
at the end of the day there's no amount
of women
who are going to fill that void if you
don't have purpose
if you don't got some kind of calling if
you don't got something that you can
truly invest in yourself
whether it's a family whether it's a
work whether it's a career whether it's
a hobby if you don't have that
eventually you pay a price and i just
don't think that price is worth it
i think i've seen it in all the men who
are around me i've seen all the men who
are highly successful who are around me
even you talk about nba players
the ones who spend all that time wasting
their time they're never the greats
these are people who are basically
wasting their god-given talent
right because of the fact that they
can't maintain a certain level of
discipline
so i just i hope that young men who are
watching this understand
that discipline is going to be one of
the greatest things that you can develop
in terms of
yeah living a life of discipline
discipline
for sure and see this is where i get
into trouble because i i i go back to
times
go watch a pretty woman with richard
gere and julia roberts
and he hired her for the weekend three
thousand dollars
you'll do the job i need to do and then
after that you'll leave
yep see i i believe in if we should have
we should legalize it we should legalize
all this stuff because
i think it'll be a lot more beneficial
to guys who don't have your level of
maturity
all right you you just got to do it that
bad go on over there uh the best little
h house in this little w house in texas
that's the horse
in texas which is why i do not demonize
sex work
no i do you know that that this is a
kind of point that i think i'd really
diverge when it comes to the red pill
community
and you know we could have a side
discussion about this afterwards you
know for me
i i grew up on these kinds of ideas but
it was never called red pill
uh but when it comes to this stuff you
know you know even the idea of like not
shaming sex workers
understanding that they have a
tremendous important relation
role in society well they yes they do
they do and people demonize them
and they have this puritanical aspect
i'm like you do understand that without
these people there would be
a lot more chaos within our society you
know they are operating in a place that
we need
and in that same token when i talk about
disciplining yourself sexually
i feel like oftentimes within the the
red hill community
it's a lot about indulgence and
indulging as much as possible and i do
feel like those ideas
are are are negative to young men
well i would say that when i was had my
time in corporate america it
amazed me how many high-flying
executives
had were married but they always seemed
to have the same executive assistant
that they called their work wife
i'm not saying that they were sexual
relationships but
i know of men who actually had their
uh assistance written into their
compensation contract as miscellaneous
as a line item
there has always been a need for
the second grade happy hour what used to
be happy hour the hour was between three
and six o'clock when men left the
factory and went home
they go to the local speakeasy local
brothel whatever whatever
drink be with men hang out with their
buddies
uh sleep with a woman and go home think
about the victorian age when actually
people had sex just for procreation
prior to prohibition men and women did
not drink together
we did not socialize together so happy
hour came from a concept where men went
to go get happy
before they went home we demonize these
things and i'm like well if we legalized
it regulated it
and understand that that's the oldest
profession for a reason and it's the
most fundamental of human exchanges
here's some meat here's some food
can we talk it's old as a human exchange
doesn't mean that's
i mean that's what we do anyway is this
called a
visa or mastercard in the house it's the
same thing
it's just by different definition and
you know just like the whole notion of
uh we talked about the safety
you know legalize most of this stuff but
see the thing is
we we don't want to talk about
the pursuit of these these things is
what throws most men off
versus the acquisition if it wasn't so
hard to get so elicit if you could have
it at will
you go focus on how often would you want
to have it first of all
so you know and that's not and that's
not a
that's not going to be readily accepted
that many people have said are you crazy
and you simply whatever and that's
i don't call it what you want to i call
it effective
that's it i think for me i just
prioritize different things in life i
think there's things
there are higher things to strive for
it's not about pleasing women or making
women feel worse it's nothing to do with
that
although you should you know obviously
respect the other sex i think it's
more so a matter of like do you not want
to do more in life than just see how
many
people you can accumulate on your on
your belt you know
you know when you have this is one thing
i really believe
and i've had conversations with a lot of
people who have high body counts and
it's just like
after a certain point it's all a blur
this is
it's and you don't look back on it and
go
man i did that you look better than like
i remember some people
yeah okay i've never admitted this to
somebody embarrassing man you're like oh
you start to feel like oh my god
oh okay and you know what people are
going to hear this and they're going to
think oh my god they're
just bragging but i had this
conversation briefly and i said there's
a certain level of shame that i feel and
it's not to tell you guys
you should feel strange it's not that
it's just this the idea i can't remember
certain people
or just the idea that like i'll
recognize
her too yeah i mean i've told that story
before
i tell the story when i was sitting
around with one of my buddies in houston
another fraternity brother of mine
and we were just going through our our
list
and then he said something man when you
stay out of my bedroom
implying saying that you got with
somebody i got with
and we were you know all testosterone
for you playing
john madden football and after you get
to a certain number you're like yeah
yeah yeah but after the numbers started
you're like uh-huh but then you started
oh i forgot about oh but then that
it wasn't a celebration anymore i got to
a point like man
i open myself up to childhood i mean
birth
sexually transmitted diseases for what
i can't i didn't even admit oh my
no so and like you said some people
think you're bragging
but i don't think it's anything to brag
about
because i think about all the time
associated with that
chasing your purpose you will always
have women
chasing women you will probably lose
your purpose
yep that's not mine that's a whole
that is i have heard that before um i
want to play
one more clip by the way am i keeping
you from something i just had two more
clips that i at least wanted to discuss
okay so i'm going to just pull this up
on the stream once again just for
everyone to be able to see
and just let me know when you're good
this is a clip on you on the roommates
[Music]
um
i'll be right back i'm listening though
i'm listening okay okay the the weight
is doing a lot man i can't say in the
black men the weight is doing the lie
because
when four out of five of our sisters are
overweight and no one can tell you
nothing
i don't know who can get through to him
um it's going we have to start having
women be honest with each other because
when you're raised in our
in our culture mom leaves the house so
they may hear it from me
but until women start actually having
let's just use it thoughtful respectful
conversations about hey we need to
probably do this
for our own health for men or whatever
because men don't care
why you do it we just want it there all
right
just gonna wait for this to end on
stream
oh yeah i think uh i'm back yes sir
yeah so did you hear that it was about
the weight and and then
okay let me just say a couple things one
one of the things i think i get accused
of a lot
and rightly so i mean
when i was before i was 30 years old you
know i was
there was the point in time where i was
pretty arrogant and i call it my
twinkling 20s the closer i got to 30
tomorrow i realized i didn't know
anything in my 20s
and i you know like a lot of guys who
are raised without a father i felt like
i had so much to prove
i've done a lot of work to become a
better version of myself
but because i speak with confidence and
passion and i'm an effective presenter a
lot of times people
come across thinking who does he think
he is he's perfect no
no i'm far from it that's why i leave up
all my videos
and show my the progression
because i realize that i'm asking people
to do
things that are difficult to look at and
this whole weight thing
i'm talking about women that i love in
my family
what if i sit there and look at what
it's doing
and but when no one can tell anyone
anything we're in a bad place and here's
the thing that i feel
personally this is my personal point of
view you don't have to hold that
but i realize that
through lots of even through no fault of
our own directly
black men in particular have lost
credibility or respect in so many
women's eyes
but they don't people don't want to hear
from you if they don't quote unquote
respect you
so the easiest way i found to get people
to
change that is when they see you doing
something in your own world
because when when we as ourselves as men
take accountability for ourselves and i
need to clean my room as jordan peterson
would say
that i need to evolve my craft become a
better presenter become this when i can
be challenged by people
and sit back and say you know what
they're right maybe i do need to
moderate that maybe i need to do this
i'm nev never get to so so damn good
that you no one can tell you nothing and
when people see that in yourself
and see that and what you're doing it
makes it a little bit easier for them to
tolerate that maybe
we need to do that they need to do
something too because
you don't say these things to be
offensive i have gone back and listened
to the criticism you're too harsh you're
too this you do that
and i've taken it in and said well you
know how can i moderate how can i use a
different word
how can i be more patient uh is it
is it perfect no it will continue to
improve as i get better
but my ultimate goal is to have better
outcomes for men
and better outcomes for women men want
women
they do my clients that's how we got
here these guys
once they were all on their purpose and
everything they still wanted what you
said i want to settle down and this and
that
and what i want them to have is the kind
of caliber of woman
that they want in their lives and
conversely so
if you can't give the opposite the
opposite sex
what it is they want
or need we'll just avoid one another
and what does that get us it doesn't get
us the outcomes we want so
more than anything else there's a
certain amount of uh
entertainment that goes on on youtube
but it's for
it's always why why are we doing it why
is
important for me the why is to start a
conversation
to get us towards better outcomes you
know the path may not be chartered we
may disagree
on the on the overall tone of this net
but if we can agree on the destination
then we got something to talk about okay
i think i think the the question becomes
at which point do we derail ourselves
from getting that destination and i
think with this discussion
i like yourself feel very much
uh involved uh because i'm always
saddened to hear how
the black community in particular is
affected by the topic of weight
this pandemic has been a perfect example
of that right the fact that black people
have been the most affected by this is
partly due
to the obesity rate the lack of vitamin
d sure but also just the fact that
through the obesity issue we've
developed things like diabetes high
blood pressure things like that
so many of our great people have been
taken away because of the fact that this
obesity issue is very difficult to
tackle
and so i recognize that we need to have
a conversation
and we need to regulate that
because it's ruining our life expectancy
it's taking away people that we love and
people that we want around us
and and as a result it's important to
have the conversation
the issue comes into the fact that there
are
historical and societal aspects to this
conversation
that have to be taken into consideration
and have to in
my opinion also
play a part in how we approach it
because
you ever looked at a very fat kid a very
fat
child like obese child isn't it one of
the saddest things possible
because a parent has put them in that
position
yep and right with the genetics that
they develop you know if you are
an obese child the likelihood of you not
being obese when you're an adult
is extremely slim to none
[Music]
and there's a legacy that we inherit
from the generations before us
especially with the black community
regards to diet in regards to
you know if you live in low income areas
food deserts in regards to
um you know just body composition it's
so difficult
it's so difficult to undo that and i
think when we have this conversation and
we just say stuff like
you just need to lose weight there's so
much more to it than that there's so
many more
other implications yes on the individual
you need to take that responsibility
uh but i think we sometimes engage in
this conversation and then we look at
other groups as counterparts like well
see they're able to do it but i think
our
our road is very different and it's very
difficult and i wonder
when you're engaging these conversations
with these women and you're saying you
are obese
right i just sometimes this is just my
thought process i'm like damn that must
be
how do i articulate this it must be
difficult to unpack
unpack everything i think that's what
i'm getting at well
i'll let me let me let me tell you this
when i engage with female influences
who are targeting women
on my show women have come in and said
i've had to back away from the subject
of fitness and weight
because they're not hearing it from me
either
so there's a college here in atlanta
spelman university all female
all-female they scrapped all their
athletics
and took that money and invested it in
collegiate health because they realized
so many of their incoming freshman women
were suffering from obesity so
we get to a point to where everything
you said was true the historical factors
the cultural factors
but there's also just a pragmatic factor
we have to be stopped being so accepting
of it
uh talking about fat shaming body
shaming we this
body positivity at what point does it
become
unhealthy where when we are sitting back
saying you can't judge
you can't this there are no standards we
accept everything
all right but who does that hurt if we
that means what is accountability for
the individual
because they know what that what
they know they know and here's the thing
what does it also do for the men
i'm sorry but ladies i've said this
before
men don't typically want me women that
weigh more than they do at their height
so what becomes the balance
somebody's going to have to accept
something and
we have tried it the other way for too
long
how about when women start accepting the
fact that for
however we got here we're here are you
doing your level best
to get yourself uh to a healthy weight
for you when i talk about weight it's
never to just go
lose weight to go get a man it's like no
no you need to do this for you
i talk about therapy no no it's for you
it's for the individual
because i would say this when i work
with female clients
it doesn't matter how much money they
have i want to look like this well
these makers are manufacturers the
designers they only
have uh clothing up to this size
it's a primary reason why i stopped uh
consulting or uh with women so much
because
the outcomes are unrealistic and it's
not and here's the funny thing
i know more colleagues on the image side
or even on the relationship and dating
side who have
be treated from working with women
because they cannot
cannot be honest with their clients and
see
i'm a cancer survivor i ask the ultimate
ask myself the question
if you can't be honest with your quote
unquote client
your patient you got to coddle it
at the end of the day something still
needs to be done
agreed i don't know how you bridge that
but i will say this and i will wrap it
up um
i don't spend a lot of time talking
about it uh from a
topical standpoint maybe individually
because at the end of the day
something that picks a lot of people off
that i say the world does not owe you
and me understanding
it is what it is if you want to get out
here in this sexual marketplace
and compete just like you have
wants needs desires expectations
standards for men
they have them for women too and we
cannot demonize
or call men something for not wanting
what you're quote unquote selling
i i'm i'm 100 in agreement with that
portion
my goal with what i'm saying is not to
say well man you need to tolerate this
because
women have been dealt with especially
black women is unfair because that's
unreasonable nobody's going to fall in
love
to support a cause that's a that's a
terrible reason to get married to
someone right
hey you know what i want to support
feminism so i'm going to just marry the
first glassy with green hair that's a
stupid
parallel to draw right right however i
do think we
as a group do have to be more mindful
how we engage these discussions because
when we just make it like
yeah i agree i agree with the whole i
premise that we can't jump into the fat
acceptance thing i've
i've raged against that because i think
it's stupid to
be like this is a perfectly acceptable
thing meanwhile the person
is at far likely higher odds of like
suffering from diabetes
this and that like we shouldn't
encourage that it's killing people in
our communities
at the same time the way we engage in
the dialogue in the opposite end isn't
healthy either like
statistically speaking from all
scientific studies that i've seen the
idea of shame
and the idea of just yelling at people
doesn't necessarily make push them
to rectify whatever weight issue they
have so if we're just talking about
being results oriented
i do think that we have to approach the
discussion in a more nuanced fashion
i agree that what they're trying to do
does it work but we can't just go in the
opposite direction thinking it's going
to fix things
the same way whether you go lean
politically left one time
you can't just go all the way right to
fix things there has to be
room for one telling the truth but also
understanding
we we have to be patient and we have to
have this conversation intelligent
matter because the underlying factors
for why we are where we are are so
complex
we as a group i just feel like we deal
with something so specific and unique
we can't just take their solutions and
think it's going to work for us
this is why this is where i started to
disagree and i'll tell you why
um one i will often tell
women that men will go down and looks to
go up to cooperation
so it's about choices and trade-offs
you got you got to pick struggles as
people you can't have
18 struggles a man you got to pick your
struggles
ladies you got to pick your struggles
too because
i can listen to everything you just said
but then i go back and i say this go to
your family album
and show me the women there with 300
pounds in in in your family album
prior to 1950. go to soul train
in the 1970s that's what we're supposed
to look like
i used to be a group x instructor and i
used to cycle heavily before i broke
this ankle
go to the gym it's not a matter of
knowledge
we know what's going on but i don't want
to sweat my hair out
i don't want to do this i don't want to
lift weights i don't get that
no push away from the table
eat a better diet and exercise you got
to do
something and see that's the ultimate
point we've gotten to
the answer tends to come back is to
however we say it it gets to be what we
need to be more understanding
understand what that you're taking in
too many calories you're not exercising
enough
i know that when my clothes start to fit
too tight and if i don't want to buy new
clothes i got to do something
and i hear this thing about
the statistics and this is but human
beings
don't vary that broadly
we have cultural differences but we
so what are we ultimately saying and
here's the sad part
and this is my personal opinion nothing
backing scientific
when you give ample wiggle room
people can people women more more so
than men in my opinion
just my opinion well we go through that
confirmation bias if you just say well
not all all right but what are you doing
because if you if you're 25 years old
and 190 pounds of 5'4
you don't have time to be slowing down
and to
coax you into it if you if your outcome
is you want to
have a husband and have children and all
those kind of things well
you are diminishing your chances
by just your sheer weight alone
and we don't want to say that but it is
true
yup and so at what point do we say
well you know these reasons or do we say
hey you know you need to do something
different
and it's up to you to do it i think i'm
advocating for both i'm advocating that
we tell people to
accept responsibility because at the end
of the day doesn't matter how many
societal things
the only person that can lose the weight
is you what i am saying is
what are we telling parents who are
raising these obese children
what are we saying on a societal level
in regards to these dietary things or
traditional some of these traditional
black foods for example that we may eat
that are increasing this what are we
doing you know like i liked a lot of
initiatives that i saw in regards to
creating like
uh you know gardens community gardens
within the inner city that like gave
people access to
because you know the concept of food
deserts the inaccessibility to
healthy foods but then you could have
you know fast food joints on every
corner that's a real reality in a lot of
inner city spots so
i just think expanding that conversation
to include that
will help people to understand what
choices you need to make because while
you and i understand yes it's less
calories
people don't know the difference between
healthy carbs and unhealthy carbs
complex
and that's the thing that's where i push
back because i assume that most people
are intelligent
i mean i especially i just
i i think and that but i give them the
benefit that they should be
when when i hear especially in our
community when black women say we're the
most educated okay well
you should know this because i know it
you're the most
but we know that's not true well you
know that's not true but but if you're
going to say it
if you're going to say it to put some
jewels in your crown i'm going to say it
to
to knock that crown off your head look
i understand what i meant with that
don't cut that up but here's the thing
honestly
yeah we it's like inner cities
but i'm looking at the the broad swath
of america
honestly i think women need to have this
conversation with women and hold each
other accountable because
men saying it can be minimized
but when women start holding each other
accountable when mothers start holding
mothers and women
when your sister tells you what do you
feed my nephew
versus coming from a man it needs to
women
have a i think especially in our
community it is easier for women to have
conversation with women and hold each
other accountable
of course because it sounds like
misogyny well and that's crazy
but i'll take it because that's what it
is but see big mama we used to be able
to have these conversations when we had
big mama but after 2003 2005 when the
big mamas were finally kind of gone
that's when the it's it's wide open
yes food doesn't exist but they've
always existed
yes all these things exist but
why are we where we are because i can't
judge her you can't judge me
only and it's just like all right well
at some point is it working for you
because
if it's not getting you kind of outcomes
you want and then trying to
increase your sexual marketplace value
with you with your degrees your money
your resources things that men don't
want
that's what tends to happen when i say
men want women who are fit
feminine and friendly and women get
upset saying well
you need to value value like tommy
lauren was talking about
no men are who they are they want cheese
pizza
you trying to tell them they should want
this they want cheese pizza simple
yeah i definitely agree with that so i i
got to run here not too long but
i i think it's i think it's i think
what i ultimately say is men are held
accountable
we are held accountable and i think that
women who may have a problem with what
i'm saying or how i'm saying
okay but who is holding you accountable
for the outcomes
you want from your life who can
and if and and are you getting them
because that is up to you as a human
being for you to get the outcomes you
want
you got to hold yourself accountable now
if you could do that in college
to get your back to get your bachelor's
seat your master's get your phd
and get this career job home whatever
but what about
the level of seriousness and focus on
the man and the family you're saying
and see that's why i'm seeing the
disconnect far too little is put over
here
on the relational things we just assume
that this is going to happen and it's
not and this is where the frustration is
leading to
and the disconnect between men and women
because the things that i'm saying
is just what men have been saying for
the longest and the barbershops on the
basketball courts
but it sounds new to women and that just
shows
all around robin that so many modern
women
do not know who modern men are we have
to learn them
they are just now starting to learn us
yeah
i i yeah on these notes i definitely
agree i i think they don't get us
whatsoever and i don't think they want
to in some situations i think they want
to mold us in a way that fits their
their perception of life and i think
it's very unhealthy it's not working and
i think as a whole men are definitely
rejecting those kinds of ideas
um so on that point i agree and i think
this is pretty much a good point i think
to to wrap up the conversation i'm
wondering if there's anything that you
would like to add
um as a closing point because it's been
a good discussion thus far yeah
i think these things are important
because
if you're going to sit up and put your
opinion out you should expect it to be
challenged
i have no problem with it but we need to
get to the point where we're challenging
the opinions the ideas
not bypassing all that and saying who
are you who hurt you
who are you to say these things what
makes no
who plus two is four al roker
is on the today show to talk about the
weather
we don't have to go all around the world
to say why should aroca be talking about
the weather who is al roker man
look because what that is is deflection
and when i i look at the deflection that
some so much of this stuff
is it's to do what to keep the status
quo
and i say this to ladies and
gentlemen who benefits qui bono
who benefits from this gender war men
and women being at odds with one another
who benefits from you paying the rent
over here and him paying a rent over
here
and we're perpetually in this
singles dating economy to where no world
has ever seen what
a bunch of 50-plus year-old
unmarried people look like uh but in
korea and japan
they're starting to see what it looks
like with not having replacement rates
for their
birth population i was in kodakoshi
where
where people are starting to die and
being found
in their places look we are going to
have to learn
how to work together so i look at this
pandemic as an actual
opportunity for a global reset to say
men and women
we do have value for one another we have
forgotten it
we have we have overlooked it we have
minimized it
but the people that are coming come out
on the other side and people who are
going to understand that i'm imperfect
he's imperfect and at the end of the day
it just takes me
as a woman sitting with this guy as a
man and hammering out a deal
all you gotta do is make a deal with one
guy and go on off into the sunset
i fix the problems of the world one to
one and i think when more people start
to hammer out those deals
whatever those deals look like that's
when you start seeing
more people in neighborhoods
and more more people starting to know
their neighbors and more people starting
to be
more connected people start to be more
connected versus less connected
less alone less isolated so that's what
my goal is so i think this is good
um i like stuff like this i like story
it can be challenged it should be
challenged
i agree i agree i think that's why i
want to bring up you bring you up
because i feel like
there's not too many opportunities for
you to necessarily do that and i think
people seeing that your ideas are robust
i think makes them change their minds
about certain things that makes them
realize like
hey maybe i need to do some
self-assessing so um if i can bounce
anything off of you in the future if you
need that yo
hit me up i'm more than happy to do that
i appreciate it
yeah this was really civil even though
we disagreed uh pretty strongly on
certain points
we can have discussions like this you
should disagree agree
and the thing is even if people look at
and say you know what
i don't agree with anything he said but
at least the fact is saying you know
what
i can understand where he's coming from
even if i don't change my mind
understand that it's coming from a good
place a good outcome
but i i want a better outcome that's all
i want what a better outcome for men and
women that's it
yeah and i think we can do this without
referring to one person as blue peeled
or
any of this stuff you purple you already
know you already know that that'll be
the evolution of the conversation
i think so we'll give you i hope so so
definitely i want to definitely bring
you back in the future so thank you for
coming on
if anybody wants to find kevin samuels
you guys can find any of his ads in the
description below just search him up on
youtube
as well but if you go to the description
of this video which i'll be leaving
public for quite some time
you'll be able to find all that
information on him and then we're gonna
probably in the future make an
appearance on his channel to have a long
form discussion so go subscribe go hear
what he has to say
um for me i think it's great that we
have uh
men who are on these platforms feeling
speaking eloquently about a lot of the
issues that we have today
and i think it's great for young men
young women for folks in general to
to hear these things because uh we need
them
you know and in the absence of folks
like patrice i'm glad we have folks like
you
yeah there you go that's big shoes to
feel man
you and i know you and i know so you
know i wanted to give him a little shout
out since i know he's uh
he's someone you really respected so
thank you very much
all right cheers
so we're gonna keep the live stream
going the way i'm gonna set this up is
i'm going to
jump into vc at the moment so just guys
give me a moment if you're still there
with me
and what i'm going to do is i'm going to
set this up a little different we're
going to have a little conversation
after the fact so what does that look
like that's a great question
um
so let's see right here this i'm going
to set it up let me go to this window
over here
here whoa look at my big ass
chin come on chill out bro whoa
what is going on inception my friends
all right here we go um yeah that was a
great discussion
i don't know how you guys felt about it
i'm going to go through reading some of
the super chats
uh but thank you guys for coming out i'm
i'm going to be doing more of these in
the future along with preach preach how
to go handle some stuff we can't really
talk about it too much
um but yeah you know i was really
grateful for the discussion i thought it
was great that we were able to talk like
this
and we'll definitely be doing things
like this in the future with other
people you know people
people who we disagree with people who
do agree with but i think it's important
for us
as a as a community people who want to
foster growth within
folks around us and ourselves in general
that we should have talks like this
civilly
and to challenge each other's ideas not
[ __ ] softball
interviews where we agree with
everything and everything's so easy
we need things where we challenge these
ideas it makes you a better thinker i
often watch people debate things
and it helps me to figure out where i
stand on issues so hopefully today's
stream helped you guys with that
um if you guys hit up our patreon we got
a lot of exclusive content eventually
we're going to be sending this to the
patreon aside
so that's going to be the only place
where you can find it but we will be
breaking down some of the portions of
this
live stream into individual videos that
we're gonna be putting on our stream
um so hopefully you guys enjoyed it what
i'm going to do right now and i think
what i promised to do was to
are people still hanging out i think
people might be hanging out
but i don't think we're going to be able
to take any calls so what i'm going to
do right now if you guys want to keep
the conversation going
go to the abba and preach instagram page
and what i will do
is i will start a live stream where you
guys can come on and tell us what you
thought
so if you guys have ideas you have
thought just you have things you want to
say
um you can come on to the app and preach
instagram that's aba
and preach on instagram and we're going
to be doing a live stream there in about
like 10 minutes
and you guys can come on tell us what
you thought of the interview what we may
have missed we want to hear your
thoughts but guys
the other day we uh we want to talk
about some [ __ ] so let's do that
and i'm gonna check out some of these oh
my god so many of you guys donated it's
crazy i was so engrossed in the
discussion i didn't even get a chance to
look at half of this [ __ ] so
y'all gonna have to forgive me i i don't
even think i could scroll up
i don't think i could scroll up you know
what listen thank you guys so much for
the donations i feel bad
next time i promise i'm gonna do better
um but
you guys are awesome you guys are
awesome i don't know maybe the chat was
trash i don't have no idea
um but i can't wait to
to do more in the future so yeah check
us out on instagram we're going live
in 10 minutes